Laurin Roden are you ever tempted to
leave civilization and live off the grid
I have curiosities sometimes about what
would it be like to sort of create a
homestead somewhere rural and you know
learn everything from out above what
would I have to learn knitting knitting
well that wouldn't be at the top of the
list but you know survival skills out a
bit construction and knitting I guess
I've been you need sweaters but I guess
you could bring clothes I have those
temptations sometimes but I never even
get to the point of looking into it
seriously I just like being around
people too much right I think it's just
based off the idea that we're so upset
with what's going on in the world with
Donald Trump and climate change and
everything else and we're so frustrated
with our fellow human being yeah that we
decide you know I'm going to detach from
humanity and live on my own I don't
really get that sensation though I think
I'm in it for the long haul for the
better or the worse for me it's not that
sometimes I just think it would be
interesting to experience life
disconnected from you know that city
that's out there and and all of the sort
of day-to-day but you know if I think
before I really ever considered leaving
civilization and staking my presence off
the grid maybe I'd let go camping for
two days ago saying you know if there
would be nothing to do for me I assumed
I'd be alone in this instance I mean
people are social creatures you can't
just deprive someone of your other
people to come in contact with even if I
imagine like I had a family already like
a significant other and a kid or two and
then I did it it still seems just as bad
to me
yeah I mean just it's just nice to go
down to the barber shop for a haircut
every once in a while it's nice to
interact at the grocery store yeah you
know I agree I couldn't I couldn't do it
so yeah Lauren it's not I mean I've got
to say am i tempted no do I sometimes
fantasize not in a completely positive
way but just sort of daydream of what
that would be like yeah I think I've had
those thoughts
I wonder what Louis MO comedy would have
yeah uh anybody's guess anybody's guess
about that